now I'd like you to meet the lady
formerly summer of 42 and the
reincarnation of Peter flood is joined
by one of the most dedicated members of
our Academy and a distinguished member
of a company of players namely Jennifer
O'Neil and McDonnell carry it
the best achievement in film editing the
nominees are Jhansi Howard and Danford
green for Blazing Saddles Sam Osteen for
Chinatown
Dorothy Spencer for earthquake Michael
Luciano for The Longest Yard Harold F
Chris and Carl kress
for towering inferno and the winner is
the winners are
we'll accept the government Oscar for
the
I believe the greatest thing that could
happen to Zeldin I that if our son was
here tonight if this is being telecast
to Russia I want to say Carl we did it
and Carly's in Leningrad working on
Bluebird I want to thank our producer
Irwin Allen who at the faith to work
with the father-and-son team and I think
this is a first for the Academy a
father-and-son team winning the Oscar I
want to thank her won John Gill ermine
all the hundreds of technicians that
helped us and God bless the Academy
thank you